abone ol
ya ben bugün vicdanı böyle konuşacağım
biraz çok güldürmeye bilir bazen bize
biraz düşündürebilir biraz kendi
hikayemi anlatacağım kendi Vicdan evrimi
anlatacağım Aslında öyle diyebilirim
orta okuldaydım ben Ankara'dayken tipi
Ankara çocuğuyum işte TED Ankara
Koleji'ne gidiyorum falan ev beyaz çok
Ankaralı sıbe TV bırakmaya karar verdim
çünkü şu fikir çok garip geliyordu bana
böyle bir şey yani annesini özleyen
bağıran koşan sevinen falan bir şey
kafasını kesip yemek biraz garip
geliyordu asla her zaman biraz garip
geliyordu Ama annem kandırıyoruz beni
sonra itiraf ediyor böyle evladım da
tavuklar gerçek tavuk değil onlar
kafasız üretiliyor bunların kafası yok
vallahi
bu yıldıza kandırıldı sonra Ortaokulu
günler kafası var mı kesiliyor yalnız
Salonu İlhak edilince Bir dahaki etmek
istemedim Çok da isyankâr bu tip olduğu
için tahmin edebileceğiniz üzere bile
ergenlikle karışınca hiç ses etmedim
yani Ama yeme evladım bize ulaşılan ne
yaparsan yap dediler olan Ankara daha
değişik daha sadece Kebapçı vardı
yüzünde Yani dışarıda yemek yiyeceksiniz
ki baktı var McDonald's var yeni açılmış
önünde kuyruklar var Başka bir şey yoktu
Dolayısıyla ya etsiz bir şey var mı de
önce tavuk köfte var diyorlar tavuk olur
mu köfte olur mu yani balık zaten
Ankara'da derler en taze falan diye ama
o kadar yaygın değil Neyse ama daha o
zamanlar süt ürünleri tüketiyorum Çünkü
süt ürünleri tüketirken orada Kimsenin
canı yanmadığı düşünüyordum açıkçası
İşte ne bileyim kaşarlı tost Ya idare et
MC pizzayı sade yemece falan böyle böyle
idare ediyordum ve onun dışında Benim
ailem ederim Dolayısıyla evde bol bol
sebze yemeği pişiyor böyle büyüdüm ve bu
bana normal geldi bu
ben sorgulamadım Yani bir için et Yenel
bir şey değil Artık neredeyse 25 senedir
Düşünsenize ha plastik görmüşüm Hayat
görmüştüm benim için aynı şey baka sonra
insan 30 yaşına geldiği zaman
bu başka bir şey oluyor bir şey bileklik
Ediyor İnsan kafasından yediğin içtiğin
şeylerin ne olduğu konusunda biraz daha
kafa yormaya başlıyorsun de biraz daha
kendini dönüyorsun herhalde ne oluyor ve
bu süt meselesi süt beyaz bir şey hep
böyle berraklığı sembolü temizliğin
sembolü falan ya hakikaten öyle mi Değil
mi bu konudan okumaya araştırmaya
başladım ve sütü korkunç bir şey
olduğunu öğrendim Aslında Birazdan size
paylaşacağım şimdi onlar da iz memeli
hayvanlar buradan hiçbirimizin süt var
mı yok demiş sütümüz akıyor yerlere
sarılsaydım sana çocuğumuz olduğu zaman
düşsek bedenimi süt üretmeye başlıyor ve
Uçucu beslemek için Aslında biz o sütü
üretiyoruz Bütün memeli hayvanlar için
geçerli Bu Hiçbirimiz bilmiyoruz mesela
sanıyoruz ki böyle efendime söyleyeyim
inektir koyundur bunların hep böyle
doğduğu günden itibaren şarıl şarıl sütü
akıyor Siz içelim diye bana öyle bir
durum yok normal inek ve koyun da bu
hayvanların dişleri ha
bu Aldıkları zaman çocukların beslemek
için süt üretmeye başlıyorlar ama
günümüz Sanayi hayvancılık dünyasında
şöyle oluyor bu zavallı hayvan cihazlar
bir kere Normalde sürü halinde yaşarken
Bizler gibi işte ne bileyim erkeğini
beğeniyor dişisini beğeniyor arasında
kavga ediyor çiftleşiyor böyle bir aşk
hayatları var Aslında sadece insanların
aşk hayatı yok ki Tabii bu zavallı
hayvan cihazların çiçeklerle tutulan bir
aşk hayata olma şansı yok ölü hakları
yok hakları ellerinden alınmış ama
hatırlayın Yangınlarda canlılar korkan
canlılar Ne bileyim Gök gürlüyor
korkuyorlar işte ne bileyim birbirlerini
seviyorlar ya da sevmiyorlar kızıyorlar
kavga ediyorlar Bizler gibi canlılar
aslında ama işte Şu kadar bir yere
takılmış lar dişi ise bu hayvanlar çocuk
üretsin diye zorla çiftleştir diyor yani
Ağır bir kelime kullanma tecavüz
ettiriyor Aslında bu hayvanlara ve
tecavüz sonucu Doğan çocukları kendinden
bile zorlanıyor çünkü
ve sütü hayvan çocuğun değil İnsanlar
geçmesi lazım Ve bunun milyonlarca
hayvan sürekli yapıldığını düşünün
bayağı korkunç bir şey yani sistematik
bir acılar evleri gibi geliyor bana
şimdi o işte süt üretilen vesaire süt
ürünleri üretilen yerler için acıka
gerçek tarafı bu o zaman hayvancağız da
başka bir yere besleniyorlar anne
sütüyle değil annelerinden ayrılıyorlar
hiç görmüyorlar annelerini bir daha ama
onlarda bebek Yani aslında 200 TL olarak
bir anne istiyorum garip yemlerle
götürüyorlar paracık yerlerde erkeklerse
zaten dönerken kafaları kesiliyor
öldürüyorlar İşte insanlar yesin diye
dişiler s hayatları tecavüz edilerek ve
süt üreterek geçiyor Dolayısıyla asla bu
gerçeği öğrendikçe süt ürünü tüketmemeye
başladı Hani bu şöyle bir şey değil
Biraz veganlık böyle şey algılanıyor ya
abi yogacı zengin işi falan ama böyle
ben ve ben olayım falan
bu işte bunu bu kimliği üstüme giyim
falan değil de öğrendikçe açıkçası için
anlamaya başladım Yani bu bir peynir
falan gördüğüm zaman O Zavallı anne
yelekleri görmeye başladım Benim için bu
iş böyle oldu Şu seviyorum Hiçbir zaman
veganım ben veganlık veganlar vegan
vegan falan her yerde bunu söylemeyi
sevmiyorum ama sadece et ürünleri süt
ürünleri tüketmeyi tercih etmediğini
insanlara ifade etmeye çalışıyorum tabii
duyulmaz tepkiyle karşılaşıyorsunuz
neyse onu da anlamış değilim Neden falan
kızıyor insanlarda istemiyorum sana
güzel çok iyi Nereden alıyorsun falan
protein çılgınlığı var ya bir protein
almazsa ölecek bak bir mavi yani bana da
var protein ne oluyor Hani bu kadın
mıyız nedir Nedir bu film çılgın Ne
bileyim işte bezelye var O mercimekte
var Sakin olun böyle bir hakikaten Bir
de bu yeni böyle Son yıllarda bir
protein aşkı türemiş durumda sanki
protein almazsa küçük gideceğiz anne
bu ama kadar bitkisel proteinleri
hayatımızı gayet güzel idam etti
biliyorsunuz aldım tepkilerden Bir
tanesini de ne yiyorsun o kadar garip
seviyor ki sanki Topraklar orayı
çıkartıyorum diyorum aşkım ya babası ne
demek Ne yiyorsun işte ne bileyim sebze
yeşillikler kabak karnabahar falan yani
e yani o ne olabilir ki beni asıl
şaşırtan bütün bunun insanlara görüp
gelmesi Bunun nesi garip Mesela ben bunu
anlamıyorum şu daha mı normal
milyonlarca hayvanı fabrika gibi
tesislerde böyle hayatı boyunca dur dur
dur kafasını kesmek Normalde Mesela işte
ben sadece sebze ve tamamlayacağım demek
mi anormal sen bunu bir türlü
anlayamıyorum şu yaşıma geldim hala
anlayamıyorum aldım tepkilerden Evet bir
tanesi bu ne yiyorsun niye yemiyorsun ne
demek proteinlerden alıyorsun işte Asıl
bu çok basit bu şimdi formülü var ve kim
vesaire beslenmesini varsa aranızda
zaten bir evet işte ihtiyacımız olan
bütün Amino asitler ette var falan bir
şekilde ben
bu işlerde bir kısmı var bir kısmı
aminoasitlerin Bazı bitkiler var bir
kısmı bazı bitki de var dolayısıyla
bunları eşleştiriyor sunuz Yani biz
geleneksel kuru fasulye pilav yemeği var
ya on numara bir yemek herkes için Çünkü
işte altı abi nasıl bir tanesinde var üç
aminoasit bir tanesinde var ikisi 12
tükettiğiniz zaman ne oluyor sana ediyor
dokuz aminoasit İhtiyacım olan bütün
amino asitleri bunlardan almış oluyoruz
şöyle bir argüman var vücut bitkisel
protein hepsini sentezi yemiyor diyorlar
belirli oranda sentezleyebilir
Dolayısıyla işte bir takım şeyleri
yanında içmemek gerekiyor vesaire Demir
konusunda mesela yeşil istiyorsanız Çay
içmemiz gerekiyor falan böyle küçükler
var ama ölümcül bir şey değil yani
ölmüyorsun etmediğin için ama enteresan
bir şekilde hani böyle bir şablon
oluşturmuş sanki İnsanoğlu et yemezsin
ölür diye başka bir argüman mesela ve
aslan kaplan da mı yemesin O zaman bana
ya arkadaşı aslan kaplan fabrikamı
kuruyor yani aslan kaplan gidiyor
savanada bir tane geyik görürse işte
alıyor mu almıyor yiyorsun
bir fabrika kuruyorsun fabrika
kuruyorsun ve en korkuncu bu hayvanlar
kafasını severek gidiyoruz yani küçük
kuzucuk Mini kuluçka seviyorsun mesaj
canım Kuzucuğum falan artık bugün
kafasını baldırda ne güzel fark ettim
kafasını kesiyorsun yani burada Aslında
Adil olmayan bir şey var Adil Olmayan
şey şu doğada hayvan Avcı gördüğü zaman
aynı Avcı yazıyor hayvan kaçıyor vesaire
Avcı onun kaçtığını biliyor o da bir
Efor sarf ediyor taktik yapıyor
kafasında yakalıyor ve hayatını idame
ettiriyor çocuklarını besliyor falan
Tabi ki döngü var ama bizim kurguladığı
mız kurduğumuz bu dünyada artık bu döngü
yok ki burada şöyle bir şey var Bizim
diğer Canlıların yaşama hakkına karar
verdiniz Biz neye göre karar veriyoruz
Biz daha güçlüyüz diyelim karar
veriyoruz Mesela ben daha güçlüyüm O
zaman bu koyunu yaşamaması gerektiğine
karar verdim O zaman hukuk nerede
duruyor daha güçlü bir insan daha az
güçlü bir insanın yaşamasına karar
verirsen o
o orada karşımıza hukuk çıkıyor değil mi
o zaman hukuk Sadece bazı canlıları
kapsıyor bazılarını kapsamıyor bizi
kapsaması ama diğer canlı kapsaması na
karar verdik neye göre karar verdik
acaba kendimizi daha üstün bir yere
koyuyoruz hayvanlardan neye göre daha
üstün bir yere koyuyoruz sanırım sadece
bu da muvaffakiyete bakıyoruz yani
Diyoruz ki biz insan olarak yapabiliriz
kardeşim muktedir im ben istersen
milyonlarca hayvana bir yere kapatırım
hayatları boyunca kımıldama larına izin
vermem yavrularını beslemek için
ürettikleri sütleri de ellerinden alırım
istediğim zaman da öldürürüm
mı böyle koyunca Aslında biraz korkunç
değil mi yani Dolayısıyla Biz
milyonlarca canlının yaşı yaşaması
gerektiğine karar verme hakkını elimizde
bulundurduğumuz düşünüyoruz şu anda bu
sistem böyle işliyor Ama hepinize
tavsiye ediyorum yani böyle Propaganda
falan yapmaya çalışmıyorum Ama bir
dakika iki dakika düşündüm Gerçekten
böyle bir hakkımız var mı yok mu ve bir
İkincisi dediğim gibi o adaletli o
Adalet ortadan kalkıyor doğada bulunan
su hayvanın kafasını seviyorsunuz
kendinize Güven diyorsunuz bir şekilde
onlara bakıyorsunuz yaralanırsa yarasına
iyileştiriyor sunuz Güven Bu güven
ilişkisi kuruyorsunuz hayvanlarımız da
ve sonra bir gün hayvanın kafasını
kesiyor sunuz Dolayısıyla orada Adil
olmayan bir şeyler var hayvan sizden
kaçması gerektiğini bilmiyor
düşünüyorsunuz Bir Avcı olarak görmüyor
Siz bir arkadaş olarak görüyorum dediğim
böyle düşünce Biraz sanki arkadaşının
sırtından bıçaklamak gibi geliyor bana
insanoğlu etmeden var Olabilir mi
Olabilir işte Hindistan'da milyonlarca
duyamıyor arka
O çok bu kadar zararsız bir şey olsa
adamlar yürüyemez değil mi yani
milyarlarca insan var Hindistan'da
örnekleri var Dolayısıyla yapılabilir
Ben bunu biraz vicdan evrimi olarak da
görüyorum insan vicdanım ortaçağ dönüm
bakın mesela herkes günü katır kütür
kesiyor değil mi bu işte dönem
dizilerinde falan da çok rahat
görebiliyorsunuz Hani gerçek Oradan da
falan var ya da mesela çocukları
öldürmek çocukları alıkoymak ve bir
hükümdar hükümran devlet bir yer işgal
ediyor ve oradaki çocukları bunlar bana
asker olacak ya sürüklüyor götürüyor
Bunu o dönemde hiç sorgulayan Yok ya da
Afrika'ya gidiyor Lara Burada deli renge
bizden farklı insanlar var diyorlar Bu
insanları biz istediğimiz gibi
kullanabiliriz diye düşünüyorlar Çünkü o
dönem insan vicdanı öyle içiyor hukuk
böyle işliyor O dönemlerde normal olan o
anlatabiliyor muyum mesela Siz şimdi Ne
bileyim 18'inci Yüzyıl amerikasında
gitseniz işte köyde kötü falan deseniz
ya da işte Avrupa'sında gitseniz niye
kötü olsun ki insan küreksiz yaşayabilir
miyiz
o orada yaşayan binlerce Asi ama işte
insan vicdanı böyle birşey Dolayısıyla
Evet şu anda vicdani olarak etik etik
olduğunu düşündüğümüz şeyler gerçekten
ettik mi acaba bütün a Bu Yaşadığım Ne
bileyim 35 yıllık hayat beni biraz bunu
düşünmeye itti ve sonra onu sorgulamaya
başladım ettik mi acaba gerçekten şu
anda bir hayvanı öldürmek ve yemek bize
ettik geliyor O Matic mi gerçekten yüzde
sonra insanlar bunu ettik bulacak mı
yoksa Yüzyıl sonra Bize dönüp Bu ne
vahşidir Medeni 70 resmen ölüm evleri
kurmuşlar ölüm fabrikaları kurmuşlar ve
milyonlarca hayvanı burada Katip
yemişler mi diyecekler acaba günahsız
mıyız Hiçbirimiz günahsız değiliz
mutlaka Hiçbirimiz sütten çıkmış ak
kaşık değil Hiçbirimiz pirupak değiliz
ama başka bir şeyin öldürmüyor olmak
hayatta kalmak için ya da başka bir
şeyin yavrusu unun hakkı olan şeyi
almıyor olmak Açıkçası beni çok iyi
hissettiriyor vs Ben bunu insanoğlu
bu vicdanın bir değişimi bir evrimi
olarak görüyorum diyorum ki size belki
biraz bunun üzerine düşünebilirsiniz
bunun Umut neresinde derseniz Bence
dünya daha iyi diğer olabilir İnsanların
daha çok iyilik yapmayı düşündüğü sadece
kendilerini değil de bütün dünyadaki
Canlıların yaşama hakkını düşündüğü ve
yaşama hakkına saygı duyduğu bir yer
olabilir Ben Tabi doktor değilim
beslenme uzmanı değilim şimdi yemem size
bu sağlıklı falan yada sağlıksız bunu
diyemem bunu bilmiyorum aslında çok
düşünüyorum çünkü orada sağlık ölçü
neresinde şimdi gün biri döner ve biz
ederse en sağlıklı insan eti
birbirimizin kesmemeye başlayacağız
mesela
Ben Antalya'dayım sağlık ne kadar nereye
kadar teknoloji kadar ilerlemiş kendi
2019 yılındaki yaklaşıyoruz 2018'in
yaklaşıyoruz Düşünsenize uzay
insanoğluna uzayı böyle Kapı komşusu
etmiş durumda Dolayısıyla hala Gerçekten
bu hayvanları toplu olarak katledip
yemek zorunda mıyız acaba Yoksa Acaba
bir takım alternatiflerle daha iyi bir
dünya herkesin her canlının yaşama hakkı
olduğu bir dünya kurabilir miyiz Benim
Umudum Var teşekkür ederim